ugh
i knew it
[Applause]
[Music]
avengers
[Applause]
assemble
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
give me that you have the little one
this is stark oh my god holy cow
you will not believe what's been going
on do you remember that we're in space
and then i like vanished and with all
that gray stuff in your hair
oh it's okay i'm certainly anyway dr
strange was there when i got back right
and he gave us this big briefing
he was purposefully just being nice to
thor not trying to quote unquote steal
his thunder
you have to remember that at that time
the hammer was still everything to thor
it was this huge symbol of
everything he'd fought for proving to
himself and to his father odin that he
was worthy of being thor
we'll have to talk about the big twist
in thor 4 now that we know there's going
to be another version of thor
and they don't have mjolnir anymore and
thor's building stormbreaker so where's
the other hammer going to come from
they're going to change a whole bunch of
the comic book
mighty thor plot to explain thor 4. i'm
working on a separate video for that
because that's like a whole big comic
book that we have to explain
but then captain america thrashes thanos
with the hammer one of my all-time
favorite marvel movie fight scenes
the reason why thanos's blade is able to
cut captain america's vibranium shield
is because the blade is made with uru
metal by the same dwarves that forged
stormbreaker
mjolnir thanos armor and the original
infinity gauntlet
and within the marvel universe uru metal
is about as strong as vibranium they
have very different properties but
that's why captain america's shield is
able to take a full hammer swing from
mjolnir in the first avengers movie
milner is made of uru metal as is
stormbreaker
the reason why thanos is able to wield
stormbreaker because it doesn't have the
word of the enchantment that mjolnir has
remember even though odin doesn't shine
a light on it very often he knows how to
cast
magical spells just like loki just like
frigga that's why he says it took me a
long time to get out of your enchantment
loki during thor ragnarok
your mother would be proud you guys will
like this too really deep cut easter egg
the russos after the movie came out
explained that the double-bladed sword
that thanos is wielding here i mean it
looks really badass by itself
but it's also meant to be an easter egg
for the blades of the thanos copter
from the comics sadly no actual thanos
copter in the movie but at least they
were thinking about it during this fight
scene
maybe we'll get a thanos copter during
the animated marvel what if series if
they do a thanos episode
during the avengers assemble seeing the
big final battle the reason why roadie
is wearing that newer upgraded iron
patriot armor is because they
crushed the last war machine armor when
thanos blew up the avengers base
and they want to sell more toys they're
doing their big double fold out splash
page scene
the most comic bookie thing ever they
want everybody popping on screen as
shiny as possible like look at all these
toys we can sell
so they put everybody in the shiniest
version of their suit that makes sense
within the story like cap
isn't gonna run off and hose his costume
down so that he pops more on screen
but it makes sense that roadie has
backup armors in the avengers base the
reason why it's the iron patriot armor
is so that people in the audience can
easily spot the difference between this
and the last version of the armor
without having to hit the pause button
and zoom in like zoom enhance which
armor is he wearing
as you see ant-man in giant man form
running in the background you see
spider-man
swinging off of him just like he did
during captain america civil war
the digital effects artists that were
working on these scenes tried to cram in
every callback that they could into
every single frame
so if some of these fights reminded you
of earlier fights that was on purpose
if you look at the bottom of the frame
here you can see shuri is wearing those
new sneakers she designed for black
panther during the black panther movie
based on the back to the future 2
self-lacing sneakers
pepper potts doesn't have the extremis
nanites in her body anymore so she's not
crazy powerful but you're just meant to
assume that the rescue dawn
inspired comic book armor is just super
powerful as powerful as iron man's armor
would be she probably doesn't know how
to use it quite as much but it's not
like he's going to send her out in a
weaker set of armor if he loves her more
than anyone else
i think the fact that they put morgan
stark in the helmet earlier in the movie
is just a call
out to someday she's going to wind up on
a young avengers team but she's so
young right now in 2023 it's probably
gonna be a while before something like
that happens
the alternate ending with captain
america was basically meant to be a swap
with him and iron man who is going to
make the ultimate sacrifice
and there were a couple reasons why they
went in a different direction and part
of it has to do with how hardcore and
graphic this captain america ending was
going to be
all right let's get this [ __ ] up
it started with thanos in 2014 capturing
nebula stealing her time travel device
in pym particles and in the original
version it would have taken ebony ma
longer to figure out how to reverse
engineer that technology so while he's
figuring that out
thanos in 2014 travels to earth in 2014
prior to the events of avengers age of
ultron
kills all the avengers in that past
timeline
ebony maw finishes fixing the time
travel device thanos and his ship
arrive in present day at the avengers
base in 2023 on the battlefield here
and when he shows up in this scene here
sitting kind of waiting for them to show
up so they can actually start the
physical fight
when the avengers walk up he tosses out
captain america's
severed head in front of them as a way
to demoralize them before the actual
fight but it was meant to be 2014
captain america's head
not this version of captain america so
already you can imagine why they chose
to cut the scene
one they said it just felt like it was
way too much and they were already
skating on thin ice with the rules of
time travel
so it was just simpler to have thanos
come straight to present day with the
help of evil younger nebula from 2014
and obviously getting rid of the severed
head helped them keep the movie pg-13
the other reason why they decided it was
going to be iron man to sacrifice
himself is because they felt like it was
too easy
to let captain america sacrifice himself
because no matter what he's always the
guy that's going to throw himself on the
grenade
and it was a bigger turn for iron man's
character more character development
that he would choose to do that himself
because normally he tries to find a way
out of those kinds of situations like i
have a trick so i don't have to pay the
ultimate price
so no this was him accepting the burden
of that i'm not going to run from this
anymore and that's why they wound up
killing iron man instead of captain
america
but let me know in the comments do you
think that they were right to get rid of
that severed head and do you think that
they were right in choosing iron man
instead of captain america to sacrifice
themselves
i've got a whole bunch more avengers end
game bonus features deleted scenes and
stuff to post that'll come in the next
couple of days
but leave all your video requests in the
comments below i'll name a giveaway
winner when i post my next marvel video
click here for my teaser video on the
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness movie
and click here for the brand new teaser
trailer for the lord of the rings
tv series thank you so much for watching
everybody stay
awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you